this episode is made possible by
dashlane secure your data from prying
eyes by signing up for a free account
today we live in a time when the world's
most valuable commodity isn't spices
gold or steel but data information is
what drives our modern society it allows
brands to target their advertisements
towards promising viewers or political
groups to spread less than accurate
attack ads among susceptible voters
companies like Facebook know what we
like what we dislike who our friends are
where we live what we look like and what
we do online the reasoning behind this
data gathering is of course presented as
a positive thing by those doing the
gathering wouldn't you rather see
advertisements for products that fit
your lifestyle and political news
stories that fit your worldview and
isn't it nice to see what friends and
family are up to no matter where in the
world they might be the presumed answer
is obvious to most people yeah that
sounds pretty convenient but in exchange
for that convenience
what are we sacrificing in recent months
we've seen an explosion of negative
reactions to Facebook's connection to
Cambridge analytic
the research firm that in cooperation
with a third party researcher named
Alexander Cogan sent a simple
questionnaire to about 300,000 Americans
in 2014 the quiz seemed fairly innocent
over a hundred easy personality traits
with which to agree or disagree in
exchange for taking the quiz users were
rewarded with a few dollars here's the
catch in order to take the quiz users
had to login with Facebook
giving Kogan and by extension Cambridge
analytic access to your personal
information including most importantly
your likes and your friends list Cogan
used the quiz to develop a personality
profile much like what you get when you
take any other online personality test
he then combined that profile with users
voting records and sent the data over to
Cambridge analytic
to be used at their discretion but it
didn't stop with the 300,000 people who
received the questionnaire Kogan's app
also harvested the information of an
additional 87 million people creating
similar personality profiles without
their knowledge or consent
Cambridge analytical then used this
treasure trove of information to target
Facebook users with sensational
political messages and CA higher-ups
were even seen bragging about their
influence behind the Trump campaign in a
recent Channel 4 News expose of course
the current administration explicitly
denies such a connection regardless of
the outcome what
Okin did was a direct breach of
Facebook's policy CEO of Facebook Mark
Zuckerberg is currently under Federal
Trade Commission investigation for
Facebook's role in distributing or
selling user data so what's the issue
here did Facebook technically do
anything wrong well yes and no on the
one hand their method of providing user
data to corporations and specifically
Cambridge analytic is shady and
potentially in violation of the law but
on the other hand some responsibility
has to fall to the user when the service
is free you are the product Facebook
wouldn't be one of the most valuable
companies in the world if it didn't have
something to offer advertisers and in
this case what they can offer is very
specifically targeted ads when we sign
up for a social media service in our
modern society we expect a measure of
privacy we expect to be able to choose
what other people can see about us some
people put every single aspect of their
life on Facebook where they live where
they went to school photos videos their
friends and family and what they're
doing at any given moment when you do
this the blame doesn't all fall at the
feet of the platform we have to take
some responsibility for our online
privacy the people who shared public
political beliefs liked right-wing pages
or lived in certain areas of the country
received very aggressive and often
outright false political advertisements
thanks to Cambridge analytic as hyper
targeted campaign and while the full
extent of the effect on the 2016
presidential election is still unknown
experts are beginning to suspect it was
more significant than previously thought
okay so what's the big deal
people who were inclined to vote
Republican or were on the fence were
shown ads that favored one candidate is
that really such a big problem to put it
simply yes if it comes to light that
Facebook was indeed in violation of the
law in providing data to Cambridge
analytic and especially if the results
of ca's political campaign are shown to
have significantly impacted the 2016
election by spreading false information
and nothing is done about it that will
indicate to these companies and social
media platforms that they can engage in
this sort of behavior without fear of
repercussion online smear campaigns and
fake news will become even more
commonplace susceptible groups such as
the older generations and the less
educated will be completely unaware of a
very real danger of being force-fed fake
or highly skewed information further
dividing and polarizing the country the
unfortunate truth of the matter is
that in today's social climate outrage
over any event passes quickly in favor
of a new scandal and without pressure
from Facebook's 2 billion strong user
base the platform may not be held
accountable for their transgressions if
the government doesn't decide to step in
and mandate changes to how user data is
handled we could be well on our way to a
system that makes the internet so
targeted that it's impossible to find
reliable unbiased information as we
enter this Renaissance of the importance
of personal privacy and the birth and
implementation of truly intelligent AI
and machine learning techniques we are
at the very beginning of what
corporations and political groups could
do with our data consider China's new
mandatory social credit system Chinese
social media carefully monitors user
data tracking people's behavior if your
social credit score gets too low the
government can ban you from booking
flights or train rides throttle your
internet speed ban you or your children
from better schools keep you out of the
best hotels prevent you from landing
jobs at state-owned corporations or
large banks and publicly shame you for
being a bad citizen the methods for
determining this score are currently
kept secret but with the amount of data
companies like Facebook have access to
there's very little standing in the way
of implementing a similar system in the
United States with or without our
knowledge of course sneaky Facebook
quizzes aren't the only way to have your
valuable information stolen it's
disturbingly easy to acquire passwords
from most people and even companies this
is particularly dangerous because many
people have sensitive documents in their
email or even worse share the same
password between email bank and online
services all it takes is for that single
password to fall into the wrong hands
and all of your information is up for
grabs some of you probably remember the
our mine YouTube hacked from April of
2017 some group managed to acquire the
password to a prominent multi-channel
network and changed the names and
descriptions of dozens of videos across
many popular channels including this one
luckily this group only used their
newfound power to advertise a minecraft
server but the outcome could have been
much much worse all this to say our
modern information age is more dangerous
than it appears unless we want a nation
in which the presidency and other
positions of power go to the highest
bidder or the group with the most
personal data we as a society have to be
more diligent and outspoken when it
comes to our online privacy
besides limiting what information you
share online
one easy way to protect yourself is to
use a different password for every
account you have there are plenty of
ways to keep track of all your passwords
but I like to use - lane - Lane is a
free super secure way to keep track of
all your passwords in one place and even
autofill login fields for each account
it uses a u.s. patented local encryption
storage system that can only be accessed
by the user one thing I really like
about - Lane is that if you do have the
same password everywhere and you don't
want to deal with going to each
individual website and going through all
the steps of changing your password each
time you can just press one button in
the - Lane app and it does it for you
automatically super quick super secure
and you don't have to worry about
remembering a bunch of different
passwords because - Lane takes care of
it for you you can also save other
autofill options and sensitive documents
like software licenses your credit card
details or your shipping address and
populate those fields when needed one
last cool feature is great for those
friends who like to mooch off your
Netflix or HBO account if you want to
let a friend catch up on Westworld or
Game of Thrones but don't want to tell
them your password you can just use the
share password function in the app you
simply send friends and family a link
that will let them log into your HBO
account but they won't be able to see or
change your password then when you get
tired of them messing up your
recommended feed just change your
password through dashlane and they're
gone
all of these features come standard with
the free version of dashlane but there's
also a premium version that gives you
even more cool features like being able
to sync passwords across all your
devices so that your data can be up to
date everywhere you need it
fans of second thought can get a 30 day
free trial by following the link below
and using the code youtube' 2018 to get
a 10% discount on your premium
subscription it's available for Mac PC
iOS and Android so whether you up for
the free or premium account I can't
recommend dashlane highly enough to
support the channel and secure your
valuable data check out - Lane at the
link below if you enjoyed this episode
consider subscribing to support the
channel and click that little bell to
actually be notified every time a new
second thought video is uploaded if
you're not sure what to watch next
check out these playlists full of other
great content thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week
you